[Music]
the impact you have on others is the
greatest thing you can do
[Music]
mary grace i met about four years ago
she had lost ability to walk and she'd
been given a prescription for surfing
[Music]
if you want to change the world you
start with the kids you teach them a
different way to be you show them
there's other options out there
and then let him run with it
the ocean's readily accessible and you
can go there anytime you want
it's there as long as you're willing to
make the journey
[Music]
my name is jean-paul garcia
and i am a professional surfer as well
as a mentor to the kids here in town
my mom and my father both grew up in a
very poor part of columbia so i was
always given this concept of being here
you're given such opportunity don't
waste it
[Music]
i can't believe you got that
[Music]
when i was 11 years old i was
misdiagnosed with tourette's syndrome
[Music]
the doctors gave me the wrong medication
and as soon as they hit my system it
paralyzed me
[Music]
jk
that was a really hard battle for me to
go through but i had to just find the
courage inside to ask for help
that's when i met jp
so i got a prescription to go surfing
three times a week and i could stand up
on my board before i could walk
[Music]
you ready yeah okay here we go
[Music]
let's not focus on limitations
let's just focus on the vibration
and let's
the lessons i learned through jp were
beyond anything i could ask for
he taught me to smile and pass it on
i definitely believe that surfing can
make children and adults more confident
once they achieve some sort of positive
reinforcement in any environment it
sticks to them
and they can't help and exude that
everywhere they go
surfing created a change in the way that
i viewed the world
that if i could share that with anybody
that was willing to listen i knew that
could only help them more
[Music]
there is wisdom in the sea
you need to listen
you